you may be wondering Jeremy why are you
wearing all black today and the answer
is simple because Ian Malcolm does not
weird everyone lives within that rule
Jurassic Park
now in 3d along with a lot of other
things so Jurassic Park has been
re-released in movie theaters in 3d post
converted 3d of course I'll talk more
about that a little bit but Jurassic
Park came out 20 years ago now cuz time
does fly and it completely smacked
everyone in the face with awe
imagination and all the things that are
the reason that movies are made taste in
movies is subjective but in my mind's
eye when I think to myself the reason
movies are made the answer to that is
Jurassic Park in the story of Jurassic
Park this really rich dude has cloned
dinosaurs on his island for the sake of
wonder in a really sweet park if you
need another reason he did it because he
could because I would if I could I know
and Malcolm would smack me in the face
but I really would and now he brings a
paleontologist a paleobotanist a Kaos
agent and a lawyer to get eaten off of a
toilet which is the greatest use of a
lawyer in the history of mankind and of
course [ __ ] hits the fan when the
dinosaurs get loosed out of their pens
and now we have kind of a thriller movie
but not just a thriller calling Jurassic
Park a thriller really undercuts it
Jurassic Park when I saw it was the most
mind-blowing experience ever because CGI
wasn't really used in movies I mean it
was used in like the abyss and t1000 he
was CGI but to this extent making
full-fledged animals that are the star
of your movie Steven Spielberg was like
I can notice the jitteriness and the
claymation can we do something about
that otherwise known as changed the
entire game of filmmaking forever by
making CGI dinosaurs that still hold up
20 years from now you watch Jurassic
Park now and you're like I have seen
shitty or CGI made in 2013 if it doesn't
live up to Jurassic Park it doesn't live
up to the standard Jurassic Park set the
bar high in a lot of things 20 years ago
and that bar is still there today what I
love about Jurassic Park is the concept
of making CGI creatures was so new at
this point that not all the dinosaurs in
this movie are CGI like that scene where
the t-rex is just beating the [ __ ] out
of that vehicle with the kids inside
that are screaming and they're freaked
out of their minds a lot of that is a
real animatronic t-rex just making that
car eat [ __ ] i mean i dilated for god's
sakes but that's when you know when
your eyes send the signal to your brain
where it's like that's not cgi that's
real and the i dilated your brain then
goes i don't know everything that i do
know this
that's real and it's alive that's what i
know as much as i praise the cgi in this
movie the fact that not everything is
cgi is just as relevant but anything is
Jurassic Park is based off the Michael
Crichton book of the same title but
really if you look at it it's it does
not accurately follow the book I mean it
does in the essence of it all and so I
get that and it works for the movie but
if you're looking for a movie that
perfectly represents the book it's not
the most accurate adaptation which is
fine because like I said it does capture
the essence of it this just goes to show
you that it took CGI dinosaurs and new
technology to take the Thunder away from
Jeff Goldblum as Ian Malcolm Jeff
Goldblum as Ian Malcolm is one of those
supporting characters that steals the
entire show fact I think they were just
filming him they're like let's just make
Jeff Goldblum the story beyond
brundlefly and he was just stealing the
show even too much for his own show his
own movie so they were like well can we
just put CGI dinosaurs in there because
we don't even know how to make that tech
happen but can we do that and then we'll
just say it's based off that one Michael
Crichton book yeah perfect okay that's
[ __ ] that didn't happen that way but
you would not know it Jeff Goldblum was
smooth he was smart he is the smartest
one in the entire group because he's the
one from the geckos like no this is
gonna fail and usually people who are
that smart do not have people skills
they're not gonna get the girl oh no Ian
Malcolm ladies man all the way he's
given Laura during that water drop on
the hand demonstration for chaos a
really simple way for her to understand
chaos and they make hand contact which
hand-to-hand contact when flirting is
did it's that important Oh Ian Malcolm
knows and he went with it I saw that
when I was a kid I was like I want to be
like that I'm still not but dinosaurs
are cool funny thing is I really didn't
notice this when I watched it when I was
a kid but the dinosaurs don't break out
of their pen and the [ __ ] doesn't hit
the fan until like halfway through the
movie maybe two-thirds of the way
through the movie but the movie does
such a good job at engrossing you into
this world that you don't care you like
the dialogue you like the interaction
with the characters you like the fact
that you're on this island in which
dinosaurs exist now when they get to the
island you have that intro where they're
all just in awe I'm the Brachiosaurus
you stomp around and you're like you the
music's kicking on and you're like
welcome to Jurassic Park doesn't quite
cover it and you were there this movie
sucks you into the world of Jurassic
Park more than
any movie will suck you into its world
ever I mean Jurassic Park does it with
aces I don't even know what with aces
means but that's what it does this movie
has something for everyone you want cool
characters and especially a really great
supporting character you have it really
impressive CGI you have it Oh wonder
danger all here you like thrillers this
movie's a thriller you want to feel like
a kid again with Dinosaurs it's in here
every grown-up knows that they love
dinosaurs when they were a kid that's
just the way the world works the
soundtrack the soundtrack this
personally is probably my favorite
soundtrack ever made I can listen to the
Jurassic Park soundtrack and mentally be
right back in Jurassic Park for about
60-something minutes or just play the
theme on repeat because it's awesome
I'll do that for 7 hours hence that's
fine that's just Monday
Jurassic Park also made velociraptors
the dinosaur to be feared before
Jurassic Park it was t-rex everyone knew
Tyrannosaurus Rex he was the biggest he
was the baddest Jurassic Park was like
nah velociraptors they're smaller
quicker and way more vicious and
intelligent if someone's being chased or
has to hide in one of those big
industrial sized kitchens you think of a
loss of raptors because it's in your
genetic memory at this point
Jurassic Park changed entertainment at
the genetic level and Jurassic Park is
awesome tacular
as for the 3d Jurassic Park 3d is post
converted 3d of course because no one
thought to film in 3d back then they're
already breaking ground with CGI and
dinosaurs let's not push it here with 3d
however the post converted 3d in
Jurassic Park is the most impressive
post converted 3d I have ever seen in my
life before Jurassic Park it was Titanic
Titanic was the most impressive post
converted 3d I'd ever seen in my life
Jurassic Park beats Titanic do you have
to see it in 3d no Jurassic Park is
perfectly enjoyable in 2d I gotta say
though Jurassic Park came out now and I
just saw it I wouldn't know it was
actually not film to be 3d it looks that
good it's great it's one of my favorite
movies ever made so go see Jurassic Park
right now that being said have you seen
Jurassic Park and if you have what do
you think it's your Isaac park where
does it right are you like oh yeah it's
a good movie are you like it's one of
the greatest movies ever made for many
reasons however you feel whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more